стипендія Олександра Семеновича
Зеленського Зеленського старшого довічна
буде
8083 грн і це краще пояснює важливість
цього питання бо всетаки я перепрошую
можна якось ближче до теми скільки б це
не було це все рівно менше 700 000 які
передають від газпрому через родичів
дакую давайте про це поговоримо з
великим задоволенням я звертаю вашу
увагу що я при цьому не
отримую жодних стипендій довічних не
оформляю своїм родичам нікого на
державний рахунок не ввішую Як деякі
колеги зі слуги народу які оформлювали
своїх дітей помічниками перекидали
дружина в одного а в іншого помічниця Ну
там вже самі розберуться хто чи я оце ми
всі бачили і за державний рахунок 8 000
грн повісити ну це називається епоха
жлобства прийшла